let's go next to Michael from Scranton
Michael from Scranton welcome to the
program
I um I was wondering
uh I just forgot my question sorry for
swearing and bye all right goodbye
there's Michael from Scranton with a
very very strong appearance on the David
packman show which we love to see let's
go to Magnus from sweet from Sweden
Magnus from Sweden I don't know that you
could have a more perfect call than the
last one but let's try Magnus hello
David Sarah greetings from Sweden can
you hear me I can hear you fine great
Excellency I'll try my best uh just one
question if my lordship green would be
Donald Trump's VP candidate for the 2024
election do you think this could benefit
the Democrats even further to it out and
vote even more sorry if what was the
first thing if what if if Memorial
Taylor green would be Donald Trump's VP
candidate
would it benefit Democrats I you know my
opinion might be different in 2024 right
now
I believe Marjorie Taylor green is
Trump's running mate would further make
obvious that the entire Maga movement is
overtly a joke like it's always been a
joke but it's now overtly a joke Trump
doesn't leave his house he gives weird
interviews and Records these strange
videos and whatever now what could
change my opinion is that Marjorie
Taylor green is now distancing herself
from the crazy magas and trying to align
with the slightly less crazy magas she's
denouncing Lauren bobert and she wants
to be alongside Kevin McCarthy so if
Marjorie Taylor green successfully
aligns herself with the slightly less
crazy part of the Republican Party
maybe her being Trump's VP would be
helpful to him but if it were today I
think green hurts Trump uh as a running
mate
yeah I just think it would be a rather
terrifying thought if minority the green
would be vice president and even worse
president of the United States insane
what happened to Trump if Trump is
president at age 78 and Marjorie Taylor
green is the VP that's a very scary
situation I agree with you
oh I also as a curiosity I know we've
been to Denmark many times but have you
ever been to Sweden I've been to Denmark
only once I have never been to Sweden I
was destined to go to Sweden at the
start of the pandemic and then we all
know what happened and now uh it is very
very high on my list I would love to get
to Sweden I think I'd prefer to go in
late spring or something like that maybe
early summer but I I would absolutely
love to go
hey welcome to visit us anytime do you
guys have that uh you you what what's
what are the dishes that Sweden is most
known for
ah it will probably be the traditional
Swedish meatballs and mashed potatoes
and the linger Jam of course right and
is it better in Sweden than at IKEA
could be your rather authentic okay yeah
sorry perfectly fine yeah I've tasting
him in another country some
they are just about like the Swedish
ones are very good I look forward to
trying that no I I will absolutely
announce when I will be entering Sweden
awesome all right Magnus thank you for
the call cheers all right there is a
very very strong strong phone call let's
go to Scipio from California a very
devoted website member at
davidpackman.com Scipio welcome to the
show what's on your mind
sir David sir protector of the realm sir
do I sound okay you sound great
okay awesome uh so I have a politics and
a food question for you okay
um so we all know the McCarthy debacle
that kind of just ended
um with the speaker how do you think
that's going to affect the Republican
Party specifically
going into 2024 uh into the general
election it's too early to say the
question is can Republicans credibly
make the case that they are now United
and stand for something over the two
years that they are going to govern or
does this rupture or fracture get worse
and worse and devolve into more partisan
infighting it's we just we have to wait
and see I don't think we know yet
okay
um very good then the food question I
have for you is I'm Mexican-American so
there's a lot of
Mexican Cuisine that I like but I know
you're from Argentina right is there any
Argentinian I don't know if that's the
right way to put it uh is there any
dishes from Argentina that uh I should
try or that you recommend absolutely I
mean there's there's just so many I mean
Argentinian style empanadas would be
very very high on the list we're talking
about oven baked not deep fried do you
understand what I'm saying right yeah
yeah we're not gonna throw those things
in a deep fryer and just fry them into
submission we're going to bake them
um the thing about a lot of Argentinian
food is that it really it's from
somewhere else like one of my favorite
dishes is milanesa but the the term
Milan Italy is literally in the name
it's really an Italian Dish you know the
the thing about Argentinian dishes
there's Argentinian style pizza which is
its own thing but Pizza is not strictly
speaking Argentinian you know
um there are so many things to try but
the oranges of many of them are really
in other countries
wow okay well uh like I said oranges uh
great well thanks for taking my call I
really appreciate it I hope you have a
good rest of your day all right Scipio
from California always great to speak to
you folks that's all I've got I know
there's 50 people who are Furious I know
it I know it but I can't get to
everybody every time we will take calls
again and I hope to speak to you soon